this morning we are taking a closer look
at the term latin x which is a growing
alternative to latino or hispanic
the word is meant to be more inclusive
it was in the spotlight during the 2020
presidential election but
how many people actually identify as
latinx hector mejia joining us live with
this special report good morning hector
hey there alex good morning welcome to
my workstation so the word latinx is
gender neutral because the x replaces
the o and the masculine latino or
it also replaces the a and the feminine
latina the movement is gaining traction
globally but we've learned that very few
us hispanics
actually use it i actually have to look
it up
i was also kind of like whoa why is
there an x at the end the greater
population remains divided
and so the x is the start but it's not
enough
the pew research center points out the
gender neutral term latinx
is being embraced by celebrities
politicians and grassroots organizations
latinx folks are going to be the biggest
voting block in this election
in 2020 apple even created a latinx
heritage month section with videos
playlists and other content not only
does our community still struggle with
internalized racism it also struggles
with internalized
prayer phobia and sexism a study by the
pew research center also found out
that most latino adults 76 percent have
not even heard of the term
while one in four u.s hispanics have
only three percent actually use it
dr erica abad is a professor at unlv
where more than 25 percent of the
students are latino or
latinx student life often uses it
to promote their events frederick aldama
has written more than 45 books on the
topic
plus a documentary on latinx superheroes
we're sort of in
in a movement as opposed to a series of
moments of representation
in the media the ohio state university
professor says
what's important here is that the
community is the one behind the movement
we've all been told by the census by the
government
you know how to self-identify and how to
call ourselves we don't need to be
prescriptive about it like telling
people you need to be
self-identifying latinx this is really
about giving us options the transgender
non-binary community experiences too
much violence on a daily basis
i don't want to see that anymore and
sometimes it's
and something as simple as recognizing
their gender pronouns
their name and the terms they prefer
makes a world of difference
and back to the study by the pew
research center it also found that
young hispanic women are among the most
likely to use
latinx we're posting a link to the full
study on our website you can check it
out for yourself
that is 8newsnow.com live in the
newsroom hector mejia
8 news now back to you really
interesting great job hector thank you
so much